- Who saw "Hamilton?"
- [Man] Me.
- Who wants to?
- [Group] Me.
- Yes, I have a good idea.
We're gonna do something
competitive on the way down and
the two people that win I will
buy you tickets to "Hamilton."
(cheers)
- I'm dead serious.
This is the
VaynerMedia's seventh year.
We celebrate our birthday each
year, take the team somewhere.
This year we go back to Lindsay
Bloom's dad's camp like we did
two years ago for an enormous
amount of hours of competing.
I think competing on softball
field and the basketball court
and the egg toss is
a great indicator to if
you're a good employee.
If you are a winner.
Today a lot of people think
they're going to be playing and
enjoying but what they're really
going to be doing is getting
analyzed for the upside.
And then tenacity in volleyball
snuck him in and now
he runs the company.
It's incredible.
You have nothing to say?
Seems like you got a hired
at VM 1 and fired at VM 7.
(laughter)
That was tough.
- [DRock] What happened?
- I got Gary a diet Pepsi.
Did not want diet.
- [Gary] I hate
diet soda so much.
We should go around and see who
knows the most Jets player and
whoever wins...
(laughter)
Gets everybody else's money.
I interview him on my Snapchat
the exclusive interview by the
kid that got hit
by the mouthpiece.
So please everybody your
name and what happened.
- I'm Andrew Forbes.
I was booing Steph as
he got his sixth foul.
His mouthpiece hit me in the
face and he was actually very
polite came over and
apologized but picked up
a big Cavs win tonight.
ESPN asked me for the rights is
running it on TV right now and
it says "GaryVee's Snapchat".
- [Man] What?
- You know how lucky Steph Curry
is that wasn't me that he hit.
I would have went, first of
all, massively overreacted.
And basically tried to get
suspended for game seven because
I would have then taken
credit for Cleveland's first
championship in 50 years.
Cleveland I did it for you.
India tell everybody
how famous you are.
- [India] I'm so famous.
Someone recognized me
at a bar last night.
- India just thinks everybody's
talking about her now.
- [India] It's true.
- You know what happens next?
- [India] What?
- You think that every
single person you walk
by knows who you are.
That's what I'm
going through now.
I just look at everybody eyes
I'm like and they're like no.
(laughter)
That's our office.
That's our lobby right there.
That woman just walk.
- No way.
- This is our office.
VaynerMedia's right there.
Holy shit.
(group cheers)
- [Shirlee] Look
at the new DRock.
- DRock you're out.
Shirlee clearly
knows what she is doing.
(screams)
My God.
- [Shirlee] DRock, you're back.
DRock, you're back.
- I really wish you lost the
camera and hit me in the face.
That would've been the best.
- [Krissy] So VaynerMedia's
ladies basketball is
going to practice today.
Our championship is on Monday.
You should come to our
game on Monday and coach us.
It was amazing.
- I was literally about the
doze off and listen to
Chance The Rapper but
now I'm too fired up.
And more competitive than ever.
DRock, we have to
send a film crew.
- [Krissy] Oh my God.
- I think we need to
record this on Monday.
- [DRock] On Monday?
- I'm serious.
I'm not kidding.
- [DRock] Monday?
- I'm not kidding either.
- 100%.
The VaynerMedia
ladies basketball--
- Finals.
(light music and
basketball sounds)
Do not throw your
mouthpiece at anybody.
- [Krissy] There'll be a
lot of swearing though.
- No way this is happening.
Why is this happening?
- [Driver] We're going to stop
here for a quick minute just
to regroup all of the buses.
Make sure everybody
stays together so.
- All right, all right.
I don't love it.
That bus didn't get the memo.
See you.
(laughter)
This sucks.
This is the craziest
shit I've ever seen.
I'm calling Roger.
What's the matter with
(inaudible) is on the
side of the road.
- [Man] He's got a real swag.
- [Gary] He is real swaggy.
(laughter)
Bless you.
- [Group] Yay!
- Bless you.
- [DRock] Bus!
- Alright it's here, let's move.
- Hi, my name is
Eric Reedmiller.
I'm a group director
at VaynerMedia.
Gary was giving away tickets to
"Hamilton" which I have actually
was fortunate enough
to see once already.
- Who saw Hamilton?
- [Eric] Me.
- Who wants to?
- [Group] Me.
- Yes, I have a good idea.
We're going to do something
competitive on the way down and
the two people that win I will
buy you tickets to "Hamilton."
(cheers)
I'm dead serious.
- Hi guys. My name
is Kenzie Levy.
I am an intern at
VaynerMedia this summer.
I'm working on the design team.
We were just kind of playing a
game on the bus and Gary's like,
"Let's do something competitive.
"Let's have everyone pick a
number between 1 and 1000."
- I do like the idea of me
picking a number from 1 to 1000
and then people going
around and guessing to it.
- I had a number in my head and
I could just feel like it was
the right number it was
basically picking a number
between 1 and 1000.
- 301.
- 505.
- 52.
- 704.
- 224.
- 575.
- My number is 26.
- 22 and 563.
- Seven.
- 94
- 756.
- 629.
- I picked 575 because
five is my favorite number.
Little did I know that it's also
Gary's favorite number so that
was pretty cool.
- And I was lucky enough to be
within 10, 12, 13 something like
that I'm not great at math.
But I'm pretty excited that
I'm getting a chance to see
"Hamilton" again
because it is amazing.
So thank you so much Gary.
I really appreciate it.
- I'm so like a little
bit shocked about it.
I got the sit next
to him on the bus.
This isn't really an ordinary
internship obviously
as you can tell.
This is like the best
opportunity of
a lifetime overall.
I'm just so excited to be
here celebrate the seven year
anniversary with all these
wonderful people that
I've met so far.
- [Gary] Clap it
up for everybody.
(applause)
Who guessed a
number under 100?
Raise your hand.
You've been eliminated.
(laughter)
Who guessed
a number in the 500s?
Raise your hands.
You are the three finalists.
(cheers)
- [Kenzie] Wait, who is it?
- Eric's second number
was in the 500s.
Which is a really
interesting fun fact.
Alright, Eric your
number one more time?
- [Eric] 537.
- 575.
- 505.
- The correct number is
555.
- [DRock] I knew you
were going to say that.
- Which you're?
- [Man] 505.
- Which I think means you're out
'cause you're 575, within 20.
And you're 5--
- [Eric] 37.
- The two winners stand
up go to the back go to
the back of the bus.
- [Woman] Oh my god.
(applause)
- Hold on let me
get this in my snap.
Let's get every
other bus very jealous.
These two people just won
tickets to "Hamilton" in
our bus game.
Let's clap it up.
(applause and cheers)
That was fun.
There are some good fun facts.
Jim Carrey is a perv.
- My fun fact is Jim Carrey
asked me to model for one of his
original paintings and instead
of doing a Q&amp;A he's like,
"I want to create with you.
"I want to share a message."
So he looked at me and he's
like, "Do you want to model for
"me and do you not
mind getting messy?"
And I was like, "Yes."
- A lot of people have pets.
- Fun fact is I had a
babysitter that
killed three of my birds.
(laughter)
- [Gary] That is awesome.
Is there a cop?
- [Woman 2] I think were
getting pulled over.
- [Gary] I don't think so.
- [Woman 2] Are we
getting pulled over?
- [Driver] He says no
trucks in the left lane.
No buses.
- [Gary] Oh.
Did you get that?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Good job, DRock.
(laughter)
- All right next story
now that I'm less scared.
- [Woman 2] We just got yelled at?
- [Woman 3] Yeah
we got yelled at.
- He said 552.
Where's my "Hamilton" tickets?
Did you guys hear
Yudkin's Hulk Hogan story?
Yudkin goes to the bathroom,
just goes into a stall and looks
over and goes, "That's weird."
(laughter)
And Hulkster goes,
"What's up, brother?"
(laughter)
Everybody's got completely
sucked in spending an
enormous amount of
time on Snapchat, right?
That's pretty much happened.
How many people here are using
Instagram a lot less than six
months ago because of
Snapchat, raise your hands.
Using Instagram less because
of Snapchat over the last six
months, raise your hands
just want to see it again.
Feel like we should go back.
Such an exciting ride.
We had a lot of fun.
- I don't need alarm to wake
up so I don't use alarms, I just
tell myself the time I
need to get up and I get up.
(applause)
- I never had a smoothie.
- [Gary] What?
(laughter)
That's incredible.
- Never got around to it.
(laughter)
- I became a vegetarian in
seventh grade because of an
episode of "Law and Order"
that had E. coli.
(laughter)
- My fun fact is my hair caught
on fire a few years ago when
I first started, the first
week I started at Vayner.
- [Gary] This is true.
Holiday party one week in she's
like, we're like talking and
she's like oh and I'm
like, "Your hair is on fire."
(laughter)
- I think AJ blew out the fire.
- [Gary] AJ like saved your life.
- As a child I
refused to sit on Shamu.
They picked me out
of the crowd--
(laughter)
- [Gary] You went to Sea World.
- I went to Sea World and
I was like five years old--
- [Gary] and you declined?
- I declined.
Decline the invite.
- My fun fact is actually
pretty controversial,
I do not like avocados.
- [Woman 4] Me neither.
(cheers and laughter)
- That's where Vayner
eight year is gonna be.
Were going to take a seven hour
bus ride in one direction and
then just back.
Just bond on buses.
Were full-pledged
big high school.
- [Woman 5] Yeah.
(light music)
- [Gary] This is amazing, huh?
- [DRock] No, Gary.
- I know what I can eat.
Ham, turkey sandwich, right?
- [DRock] I don't know
why you are asking me.
You said, "No, Gary," before.
- [DRock] You're
going to go for dessert.
- [Gary] No, I was not.
There's so much I could say
there's so many feelings you
have when you're building
something but I'm personally
very excited about where we
stand and where we're going.
I'm excited about this group
that's here and I'm excited
about the groups coming over
to Hudson Yards and
where we're going.
We can do this because were
more talented than everybody.
The reason we can be this is
'cause we are more talented.
We're just better.
We're going to win anyway.
We can win being
nice to each other.
It's just going to happen.
The legacy of what we're
building is real.
And it drives me the most.
And I'm really really, really,
really glad that we get
to do it together.
I love you guys, thank you.
(applause)
(light music)